Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
You might have heard that Power Posing affects how powerful you feel and can change hormone levels.
If it does we’d expect to see that effect
over and over and over.
Study after study.
And it would be pretty disappointing if one
study concludes that eating carrots improves
your vision, and then after you rushed to
sign up for monthly carrot deliveries...5
similar studies find no evidence that munching carrots is good for your eyes.
To make sure that an experimental result is
sound, we want to replicate the findings.
Results need to be confirmed.
Which is why replication--re-running studies
to confirm results
--and reproducible analysis--the ability for
other scientists to repeat the analyses you
did on your data--are essential in science.
These issues affect basically every field
from Artificial Intelligence research to social science.
INTRO
A few years ago scientists at a biotech company called Amgen decided to try to replicate more
than 50 big-deal cancer treatment studies.
These were studies that had been published in respected journals.
And the Amgen scientists were only able to
replicate the original results 11-percent
of the time.
In another reproducibility study...a group
of 270 scientists re-ran 100 psychology studies
that had been published in 2008 in top-notch journals.
Fewer than half of the published results were replicated.
Stanford researcher, Dr. John Ioannidis has
claimed that “false findings may be the
majority or even the vast majority of published research claims”.
The journal Nature published a survey a few years back and asked researchers if they
thought there was a reproducibility crisis
in science.
52% called it a “significant crisis” another
38% called it a “slight crisis”.
And 90% of researchers thinking they have
some size of crisis on their hands is big deal.
The “replicability crisis” has been used
in political debates to undermine scientific
research.
Political activists, especially those that
hold opinions that run counter to scientific
research, have jumped on the problem of replicability as a way to discredit science more broadly.
And when a medical study winds up with invalid conclusions researchers could head down
the wrong path people could get misguided
treatments based on faulty conclusions they
could get sicker even...and a whole lot of
money could be wasted researching and providing
those treatments.
So, what’s causing science’s replication
problem?
There are a lot of answers.
Some of them involve unscrupulous researchers--researchers that are more concerned with attention and
publishing and splashy headlines than good science.
Here we’re talking about fraud.
Falsified data.
Intentional p-hacking.
Statistical evil doers.
But many reasons scientific studies aren’t
replicable are less nefarious.
One issue related to replication--re-doing
studies--is reproducibility of the analyses
in a paper.
There’s not always one prescribed way of
analyzing a data set.
A researcher named Brian Nosek and his team invited 29 groups of researchers to analyze
the same data set--and attempt to answer whether or not soccer referees give more red cards
to dark-skinned players than light-skinned
ones?
Seems simple enough.
These researchers were all working with the SAME data--but they ran different tests.
Some used linear regressions.
Some went with Bayesian models.
And it’s not just the models that the researchers could have differed on.
You also have freedom to exclude different
outliers, or look at different groups.
Twenty of the groups found a statistically
significant relationship between skin color
and red cards.
Nine groups didn’t.The point, says researchers, is that no one analysis is gonna find THE
answer, THE singular truth.
When researchers aren’t clear about how
they analyzed their data, from which data
points they excluded, to the exact model they ran, it can make it hard for someone to reproduce
their results.
Even if they had the same data.
Good papers will have detailed descriptions of researchers’ methods.
When you replicate a study you usually know what model the researcher used or you can ask.
But if scientists aren’t clear or consistent
about this, it just puts another roadblock
in the way of good replication.
There are other reasons for the replicability
crisis.
Some researchers and the folks who report
on scientific research don’t fully understand
p-values.
They make claims that statistical evidence
doesn’t support.
Back in 2016, the American Statistical Association released a statement meant to help researchers
understand and use P values better.
It was reportedly the first time the 170-plus
year old organization made this type of explicit
recommendations.
Among the guidelines the Statistical Association published: “Scientific conclusions and business
or policy decisions should not be based only on whether a p-value passes a specific threshold.”
And "A p-value, or statistical significance,
does not measure the size of an effect or
the importance of a result.”
P-values need to be understood in context.
A significant result doesn’t mean we ought
to all rush out and change what we’re doing.
But if you like carrots, by all means keep
eating them.
Another reason science produces results that can’t be reproduced is that published studies
have a bias toward overestimating effects--in part because they were published because they
had a low p-value.
Some studies look promising and then aren’t reproducible because they were based on a fluke.
When the study is repeated the fluke doesn’t
repeat itself.
The website fivethirtyeight offers up this
explanation: Say you were looking at the relationship
of height and college majors.
You gather up your data--including a class
of math majors with a few exceptionally tall
kids and a class of philosophy majors with
an unusually short student.
When you compare the averages-- ha ha!
Look at that!
Math majors are taller than philosophy majors.
You have statistically significant results
but when you repeat the study those differences
disappear there’s regression to the mean
which gives you a more accurate picture of
pretty similar average heights of each major and nothing all that interesting to write about.
Except a correction to your first paper.
Small sample sizes also get blamed.
The fewer subjects in a study, the more likely you get skewed and unreplicable results.
DFTBAQ, my friends.
Even when results make sense to you--DFTBAQ.
So where can researchers start improving the process--to help solve this reproducibility crisis.
For one, researchers argue they need to do
a whole lot more replication.
Replication allows us to weed out false significant effects: the flukes and the “too good to
be true” effects that unfortunately make
great headlines.
We need to get rid of the idea that one significant test is solid proof of anything.
It isn’t.
In fact, we need to get rid of the idea that
one significant test is even great evidence
of anything.
But replication is expensive.
And it’s not as sexy as making a new discovery.
It doesn’t attract the same media attention
institutional acclaim or funders.
Who wants to say “I found the effect that
my colleague found yesterday!”?
So say researchers we’ve gotta come up with ways to change those incentives.
We need to find more funding for replication studies and change the way we all view the
value of replication.
Some people call for more publication of “null results”--those that DON’T support the hypothesis.
This would allow quality research to be published, even if it didn’t show an effect, making
p-hacking a little less enticing, since you
could still get null results published.
Some researchers argue another way to help correct the reproducibility crisis is by reconsidering
the standard p-value cut off of .05 for statistical significance.
Is it stringent enough?
Or should researchers move  it?
In 2017, a group of more than 70 researchers co-authored a paper calling for a change in
the default P-value threshold from .05 to
.005.
They wrote: “This simple step would immediately improve the reproducibility of scientific
research in many fields.”
Calling results with a p-value of less than
.05 statistically significant they argue results
in a high rate of false positives...even when
that research is done correctly.
Let’s just look at one area of research
we’ve talked about before: Social Priming
-- the idea that certain actions or conditions can affect the way you behave.
One famous case of social priming is a study where subjects who were exposed to words related
to old age--like Florida, bingo, grey, or
retired--walked more slowly after exposure
than those who were shown neutral words.
But recently, many researchers have expressed concerns that some of these social priming
results may not hold up.
When they began to see that, many experiments were done with many different priming mechanisms
and outcome variables.
And we’re making this data up here, but
let’s say that out of 1000 studies done,
about 10% or 100 ended up with real effects of social priming.
This is a table that displays how often our
studies resulted in true positives, false
positives, true negatives, and false negatives.
The top row shows the 900 studies where social priming DIDN’T work.
Because we used a threshold of 0.05, 5% of those 900 studies will still be statistically
significant even though there was no effect.
Those 45 are our false positives.
That leaves 855 studies where social priming didn't work and we caught it.
Those are our true negatives.
The next row contains the 100 studies where social priming DID work.
In those studies, there were actual effects
of social priming.
There you can see our true positives (60)
and false negatives (40).
So what does that mean?
Well, remember, statistical power is the ability to detect real effects.
Sometimes we can fail to get a significant
result, even if an effect of a certain size
is real.
One estimate suggests that most psychology studies have an average of 60% power.
So, that 60 on our table represents the 60
studies that had a significant effect that
was observed.
The other 40 weren’t caught, giving us false
negatives.
Using our table, we can look at the percent
of significant results that come from studies
with no effect.
Our “False Alarms”.
Our False Discovery Rate is 45 divided by
105, or 42.9%.
That means of all the significant effects
that were recorded and published in our thought
experiment, a bit less than HALF of them are false positives.
Which shows, as we mentioned before, that having a statistically significant effect
doesn’t make it REAL.
All else being equal if we had changed the
p-value threshold from .05 to .005, we would
have way less false positives.
To make the work of reproducibility easier,
there are also pushes underway to encourage
researchers to share their data more widely.
In the United Kingdom, for example, many research funders expect researchers will make publicly
funded research data available--recognizing the data as a public good.
Academic journals also play a role in the
conversation around reproducibility--many
of the most prestigious journals have adopted guidelines and policies that put more emphasis
on reproducibility and transparency.
In part, to help boost public trust in science
and the scientific process.
Let’s go back to power posing before we
finish today.
Really get that blood flowing.
Confidence building!
A study on power posing was published in Psychological Science back in 2010 that showed that power
posing could change hormone levels and boost confidence.
A TED talk about power posing was viewed more than 40 million times.
Want a raise?
Respect and awe from your friends and family and enemies?
Power pose.
Or not.
After power-posing went mainstream other researchers tried to replicate the study--with a larger
sample--and didn’t come up with the same
results.
Other researchers found significant problems with the original study and came to the conclusion
that quote “the existing evidence is too
weak to justify a search for moderators or
to advocate for people to engage in power
posing to better their lives.”
Power-posing got labeled pseudo-science.
And then in 2018 the original author published a response to some of the critiques about
power-posing...with an analysis that suggested the poses could help people feel more confident
and powerful.
Now, the newest paper doesn’t seem to address all of the critiques about Power Posing study
but it comes to the conclusion that researchers shouldn't give up research about the effects
of Power Posing quite yet.
No.
These are not power poses.
I’m just trying to find something that indicates confusion.
This back and forth of the power posing debate does make it harder to know what’s likely
to be true.
But it also shows the VALUE of replication
and even the reproducibility crisis in research.
Science is a push and pull of ideas--researchers are constantly iterating and expanding on
ideas that came before.
They refine results.
Build on other people’s findings.
Replication is an essential part of the path
to scientific progress and real breakthroughs.
The reproducibility crisis means more people are taking the replication step of the process seriously.
Replication has helped us accomplish some pretty important things.
Like help change peoples minds about whether smoking caused increases in lung cancer, even
though researchers could never do a Randomized Controlled Trial to demonstrate causation.
Evidence piled up, and now smoking rates are incredibly low.
No single study is gonna show us the way the world REALLY is but that study and the studies
that follow it that do and don’t find the
same relationships will get us closer and closer.
And one day maybe we’ll know--with more
explicit certainty whether or not we oughta
be putting on our hands on our hips and doing the wonder woman before a big job interview.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see
you next time.